tonight we're connecting with a savings
expert to find out what great deals are
being offered now and what you may want
to wait another month to purchase krista
mcgrath from offers.com says hot items
to buy now include 4k tvs you can check
out sales at costco amazon and best buy
department stores mark down lemons early
in the year bedding and towels are on
sale at places like macy's bed bath and
beyond and jcpenney she says you can
also find great deals on beauty gift
sets at sephora and ulta this month as
well as other retailers with deals on
computers fitness equipment holiday
decor and winter clothing but mcgrath
says you're going to want to wait on
buying jewelry
early february and january kind of gear
up that valentine's shopping season so
the demand is high but if you wait until
right after valentine's day um you're
gonna find some really good deals on
jewelry better than what you're you'd
likely find now
and she suggests waiting on purchasing
major appliances and mattresses she says
you'll see better deals on those items
leading up to mlk weekend
i thought we were done shopping for a
while after